so let me walk you through the mantras
of survival
could i have your attention please first
cover is for cowards yeah that's right
you can use cover nobody stop
but you're a biological sledgehammer act
like one
chuck yourself into the fray two your
powers are on tap
you feel that tingling in your
fingertips
your powers are ready to be unleashed
don't keep them waiting
three you've got to kill to heal
there's no use licking your wounds want
your health back
get out there and take it violence
breathes vitality
finally a guiding philosophy to end you
have to think aggressive
with the mantra trailer we have
introduced a sort of
set of rules to live by on enoch
outriders has plenty of choice when it
comes to combat from
the clash you choose to the weapons you
choose to wield
to how you decide to approach any given
enemy encounter
player choice is catered to quite
carefully but i will say this
outriders is a game that rewards
confidence from the short power
cooldowns to the class-related
kill-based healing you have to play this
game aggressively
so if you live by those mantras you just
might be able to make it to the high
difficulty expeditions that we discussed
on the last show
little reminder somewhere around here
for anyone who might have missed it
this is the place where advanced players
really get to test their skills
it's a vicious but highly addictive post
campaign mode we call
expeditions but
once again i'm conscious that i'm
telling you how to play
rather than showing or you experiencing
it for yourself i mean the demo
is here after all which feels like
a pretty good segue into a much closer
look at what you can expect
in terms of content within the demo so
here's me again with 10 things you need
to know
about the outriders demo
you want a demo oh we'll give you a demo
ever since we first revealed outriders
last year fans have asked when they
might be able to get their hands on the
game
and yes we can confirm that there will
be a public demo for outriders
coming february 25th 2021
and this won't merely be a single quest
or a 30-minute snippet
nope this demo will feature the entire
opening chapter of outriders
no holds barred it is huge with around
three hours of gameplay and brimming
with content
and things to do that will give you a
great idea of what the full game has to
offer
almost looks like home that's what
worries me
as if you needed any further persuading
here are 10 reasons why you need to play
the outriders demo hope you all brought
your galoshes
number one find your class all four
classes in the game
trickster pyromancer devastator and
technomancer
will be available for you to play
through the demo with to experiment and
find your perfect class
will you be a tank pyro or a dps
devastator
mix and match abilities give them a test
run and
find what suits you and there are hours
of gameplay to be had by putting all the
classes through their paces
once you finish with the technomancer
for example
why not go back and see what the
trickster has to offer you'll need to
pick a class before playing co-op which
brings us on to
number two multiplayer this is the first
time you'll not only be able to hop into
the world of enoch
but with the help of your friends too
outrider supports up to a three-player
team to tackle missions
explore the world and progress through
the story together
you can find a matchmaking terminal in
your camp if you're looking for squad
mates but don't worry if you jump into a
lobby in which a player is further ahead
in the story than you
the game will warn you before you fully
join to avoid any spoilers
more info on matchmaking and online play
can be found in episodes 2 and 3 of the
outriders broadcast
so check those out if you haven't
already
number three cross play following on
from multiplayer is that the demo will
support
a complete cross play experience
this lets you play the demo with your
friends and other players
no matter what system they're on
the demo will have crossplay turned off
by default as it's still a beta version
but just head over to the options switch
it on and you'll be good to go
playstation 5 xbox series x and
s playstation 4 xbox one and steam
on pc no matter your preferred platform
you can play outriders together
number four transfer your progress if
you try out the demo
and decide to go all in for the full
game you won't lose your progress so far
and can transfer it across
this even includes if you play the demo
on current gen and then buy the full out
riders experience on next
gen as players will receive a free
upgrade to playstation 5
and xbox series x and s versions
don't say we never give you nothing
number five
an epic journey the outriders demo
showcases the prologue of the game which
introduces the
entire story this is a true rpg
at its core all right tell me the truth
you think the eca's thought this whole
plan through
a mystery hides at its center where is
this strange
signal coming from what does it mean
the demo will give you a sample of the
epic journey you're about to undertake
number six side quests we won't restrict
you to just the main campaign in the
demo
it's warming with side quests which are
replayable
and will adapt loot and enemy skill to
your current
character level feel free to take on
other missions from npcs and really dig
into the layers of this environment
and its inhabitants what happened here
what does it [ __ ] look like we got
mutilated
side quests won't all be unlocked
immediately though
certain ones have criteria to meet
before you can tackle them good to see
you again
with some only becoming available once
you've defeated the solar tower boss
see if you manage to find and complete
them all
number seven weapons shooting is
interwoven in the dna of people can fly
as a studio
with gunplay classics like bullet storm
gears of war judgement
and painkiller outriders is a
continuation
of satisfying shooting you might notice
that you can dismantle weapons that
don't take you fancy
in exchange for parts also you may well
come across all deposits throughout the
demo
these both relate to the expansive
modding you can unlock later on in your
journey within the full game
remember saves are transferred within
the same ecosystem
so feel free to mine to your heart's
consent and have that loot handy for the
full outriders experience
more info on modding can be found on the
outriders youtube channel
so give the weapons a go whether you're
the up close and personal type or prefer
to pick off from afar
number eight powers but combat
isn't all about the guns oh no
the anomaly storms on enoch have granted
you unique powers
evolving you into a species called
altered
as you progress you'll unlock more and
more abilities
that are exclusive to each of the four
classes from scorching waves of flames
to bending time in space to summoning up
an army of aiding assault weapons
to shoving a stone spike through your
enemy's spine yeah
you get the idea powers are prevalent in
the outriders demo
and cooldowns are minuscule now you
won't have access to
all eight powers within the demo you'll
unlock the first four
the latter half coming later in the game
try mixing up different combinations
and see what outcomes you achieve number
nine
create your outrider a staple of rpgs
and
let's face it the menu you probably
spend far too long on
is character creation and did you know
you can change the look of your
character on the fly within each camp
in the full game this means you can
evolve your look as you go
but even in the demo there's a camp
where you can switch things up
fancy a new hairstyle or adding a badass
piercing get customizing
number 10 play aggressive
in outriders the scared hide and the
hesitant
die because the key mechanic in the game
is that you need to kill
enemies to heal
with powers on tap and four in total
that you can switch
in and out within the demo and yes you
can even hot swap them mid gameplay
there's no shortage of carnage to create
on the battlefield
light them up slice them into
employ a turret barrage or crush them
into dust get out there
outrider keep updated with all things
outriders on our social media channels
remember to subscribe to our youtube and
join us on the road
to launch thanks for watching and we'll
see you
on enoch
great stuff lucy ah lovely intonation as
always
so that is pretty much everything you
need to know about the outriders demo
then and hopefully you can see that
there's a lot
in there and we are super stoked to hear
how you all get on with it so
please do let us know drop us a message
let us know on social media or
any comment section that floats your
boat we would love to hear how you get
on with it
alrighty something of a bit of a
different flavor up next
a question we get a lot on the outriders
team concerns the pc
version of the game and the surrounding
features of the pc
platform in general so today we wanted
to shine a light
on exactly that sven my good friend
take it away
we know how important specs stats and
options are to pc players so we created
this video
just for you today we're going to
showcase how outriders shines on pc
covering everything from the essentials
all the way to the tiny details that
make a world of difference
here are the topics we'll be covering in
order fundamentals
the bare necessities such as system
requirements and graphic settings
quality of life improvements the things
that will generally enhance playing
experiences
and extra goodies aspects that may
enhance your enjoyment beyond the game
based on the hardware or software you
own
let's start with the absolute basics
here system requirements
as you may see our aiming works to
target a minimum of 60 fps
regardless of what spec machine you're
playing on with cpu from 2012 and gpu
from 2014
basically if you bought a desktop from
the last 6 years you'll be fine
to be completely honest we tend to
market our games using high-end pcs
but are also aware that the average
gamer may not have such a setup
we want to be transparent here so take a
look at this short segment of gameplay
using the minimum recommended and ultra
settings
and this brings us neatly to the
all-you-can-eat buffet for all your gpu
lovers
all of the basic and advanced graphic
settings that can be changed to suit
your pc's capability
let's start with the general display
settings which lets you set up basic
stuff like your preferred resolution and
monitors
a cool thing to point out here is the
possibility to lock and unlock the frame
rate however you see fit
and the options to adjust your general
field of view something we come back to
in a bit
our advanced settings will let you go
even deeper
next to the common presets you're able
to adjust about anything
related to the visual presentation of
odd riders
mouse and keyboard support wait is that
even a question
of course we have that and as typical
with most pc games
there will be key remapping
functionality to suit your personally
preferred layout
more of a pet person our drivers will
also support most first party
controllers including steam
xbox and ps4
we've integrated support for 13
languages with the majority including
interface
full audio and subtitles let's get on to
the quality of life stuff
outriders will support a full cross-play
experience
meaning you don't have to be making any
difficult decisions about where to buy
the game
you will always be able to play with
your friends no matter their platform
hey you're welcome
we've got you multiple monitor and
ultrawide screen elites covered too
outriders will feature native ultra
widescreen support to feast your
eyeballs on gorgeous vistas or bloody
battlegrounds
this will alter the output resolution on
the fly depending on whether what is
happening on screen is creating a
processing bottleneck
essentially drs preserves frame rate and
graphics quality by temporarily reducing
the resolution until the blockage has
been bypassed
theoretically you won't even really
notice when drs kicks in
and on that note here's another brand
new feature we haven't talked about yet
we are proud to announce the support of
nvidia dlss
which uses ai-based super resolution to
boost frame rates while generating
beautiful
crisp game images and there we have it a
brief look into what you can expect from
outriders on pc
don't forget to check the outriders
youtube channel for the full pc
spotlight video
stay safe out there people and i'll see
you all soon
back to you lucy thank you sven
so with the demo news and an in-depth
look at what the pc version of outriders
can offer
we've answered two of the community's
most frequently asked questions but
we're not gonna stop there
oh no we are gonna round out the show as
always
with a community q a so robbie you're up
next
thanks lucy hi everyone and welcome back
to a jam-packed outriders q
a in this broadcast we're answering the
big questions on demo and launch
so let's just jump right in how does the
game run on previous gen hardware and on
older pcs we understand how important it
is for people to see a game on their
platform of choice before committing to
buy it
however with multiple generations of
consoles as well as pc
showing all of these is harder than ever
that's why we've made the demo available
on as many platforms as we can to let
you all jump into enoch
and get a taste of the exact experience
you will receive when you get the full
game
what is the release date of outriders on
stadia
perhaps you saw last week but art riders
will be launching on google stadia
april 1st 2021 in line with
all the other platforms we're really
excited to bring the game to the range
of devices that stadia opens up
and i'm pleased to announce that the
game will be taken advantage of stream
connect
an exclusive stadium feature that will
allow players to see what their fellow
art writers are up to in co-op play
with a picture and picture overlay i've
heard outriders is coming to nvidia
geforce now ah
you've heard correctly as revealed
earlier this month
outriders will be coming to nvidia
geforce now at launch 2
meaning if your internet connection is
up to the task
you can enjoy outriders regardless of
your pc's age
or output geforce now transforms nearly
any laptop desktop mac shield tv
android device iphone or ipad into a pc
gaming rig you'll be proud to play the
game on so those of you who are
interested in trying out riders using
geforce now
you should really consider giving it a
go tomorrow with the demo release
a few more additional questions were
answered on our online faq so go
and check them out on our website now
finally
as a special surprise treat for everyone
we are stoked to announce that we have
partnered with pearl park creations to
create
a series of custom xbox series x
[Music]
controllers
while we won't be able to put these on
general sale we will be running plenty
of giveaways for them via the outriders
social channels
thanks to everyone that sent in their
questions keep using the hashtag
outriders
stay tuned to our social channels to ask
us any questions related to the game
back to you lucy cheers robbie and with
that we are at time for today's show
remember the outriders demo is available
from tomorrow on ps4
ps5 xbox one xbox series x
and steam enjoy your first foray into
enoch
have fun and go and kick some ass
we'll see you later
you